your mission should you choose to accept
it I wonder did you have to choose not
to the end or was feared is coming and
the blood will be on your hand
the fallout off of all your good
intentions you had a terrible choice to
make in Berlin one life over millions
and now the world is at risk this is the
CIA's mission if he had held on to the
plutonium and wouldn't be having this
conversation this Tim you'd be dead
yes they would that's the job
[Music]
you don't understand what you're in
often you need to walk away
please don't make because for you how
many times has hunts government's
betrayed him disavowed him cast him
aside how long before a man like that
has had enough
we are
so how is he oh you know same always
there
what you doing find it best not to hook
[Music]
and we weren't expecting you my father
just died so he came to won the run why
else would I be here hello st your wife
she won't be distracted by Ronnie's
return we all poor firma for everything
we never thought we'd see you again
sorry to disappoint you and you're not
married
Tim Borden then this week is conducted
with honor it's the most important thing
oh no this is my house we're talking
about I keep it in order
how did you get married think he felt
that marriage would cure me
[Music]
on it you SD what's happened tell me the
truth I need to stop this
I think you should leave him I'd do
anything for you you know they look at
me this way
[Music]
I want you to give me my freedom I want
to take your picture
[Music]
a rescue George he was 2 years old he's
not just a friend he's family don't move
a muscle
are you crazy don't move
very funny you and I laughing at your
joke new guy you know bad he cry you can
get up now
and check your diaper come on your
message about Georgie okay George it's
okay
is it mirrors he considerably bigger
though he's definitely bigger I need to
find someone who knows exactly what the
hell this thing is I found her no that's
a lie technically she found us what's
happening to my friend are you familiar
with genetic editing changes will be
incredibly unpredictable increased
strength George speed agility
Phil's and saints they can run Where's
George I need to see him he is dangerous
me too man
we've created the next chapter in
natural selection project rampage works
we've got another one of your little
science experiments running around what
do you mean
of course the wolf flies
this time we throw everything we can at
these things and give people the hell
out of that city let's go save the world
that's a big arm don't fight it
you know there are other ways of dealing
with people I do know that yeah but
that's not fun
George okay ready to do this buddy
you
I think we pissed them off
good
right no here about my father was you
started out just like you this is our
time and we are Earth's lost defense
[Music]
now help me take the love let's go
already three two one
these things ain't that tough there's
something you need to see
well he's pretty big plan B always a
plan B we've got this
that's what I'm talking about
Lasserre absorbers
[Music]
I think I could get used to this your
mother
trampolining
superheroes are illegal you wanna fight
bad guys defines Who I am
we're not saying you have what someone
on TV said I was approached baddest
tycoon most talked-about hero stuff help
me bring supers back into the sunlight
we need Elastigirl
[Music]
kids no problem not the way you're
supposed to do it dad they want us to do
it I don't know that way why would they
change math over Dusseldorf do those are
dogs yeah I was so heavy paratroop he
[Music]
closing I couldn't have done this if you
hadn't taken over so well I've got to
succeed so she can succeed
1068 Bob is freaky but I can't keep
giving him nobody today done properly
parenting is a heroic act
done properly do you remember the first
time you saw the dinosaur thank you we
don't really believe it it's like
a miracle something's coming this is
your ex is the dirt it's not a t-rex
we'll come with me you know you can stay
here
Jurassic world the island
you're our easy girl all of that is in
the past my dad I got kid
I want to show you the future what is
that thing they made it
you need to get us out of here yeah are
you shopping for a gift kind of browsing
for me
so sizing is a little limited here in
the store but you could probably find
your size online I have a crazy idea
let's be honest for a minute no matter
how many times we hear it's what's on
the inside that matters women know deep
down it's what's on the outside that the
whole world judges okay I'm just like
dealing with low self-esteem and like I
want to punch you right in your dumb
face right now do you have every rib
that I have I've been on all of these
sites
no one even looks at the profile they
only care about the picture and I'm sick
of it
always wondered what it feels like to be
just undeniably pretty
okay you hit your head pretty hard
[Music]
post fix it dang I see y'all didn't I
know you don't recognize me
that's me you can use it's me Renee
what's happening Oh full spin that's
really clever
what's forward what's your number give
me your phone I'm gonna give you my
number are you still talking to me shake
it out now if iowa's you this would be
quite a large promotion for you what do
you call this exactly I get it and yes
modeling is an option for me it's not
who I am
things have really changed for me you
just have all the confidence in the
world I think a lot of people can
pleasing this the thing that really
makes them awesome and you're not like
that DJ hit it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
shimmy shimmy shimmy I should be out you
may wanna you know sneak peek means
you're completely you could just hear
people whisper Andrew I wouldn't be
surprised that he's as good today as he
was back there oh my girlfriend is the
50th anniversary of Rucker Park this
term is the center of the street Ball
universe what makes you think you have a
chance
similar like you cabana old school with
the new school I'll do it on one
condition anything you want it's gotta
be Monty my roster okay anything but
then don't be slamming my door sorry
you look like Wolverines grandfather
that's none of my business that's your
look hey hey put your baby behind his
back you let this man still curry
yo baby yo what up so what show we face
here - take it I'll tell her free today
[Music]
you were sad the only way to defeat was
enemy is to become one's enemy wait what
wait wait you crazy you psycho
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't stop playing because you beat
a hole you know because you stop playing
that sucker punch is the first free
throw you have me
[Applause]
[Music]
I was born into war right into it people
think they understand pain but they have
no concept of it what's the most pain
you've ever felt maybe the gun that
leaves you more machine than man wait no
stop
what in the actual ass Dale what why why
are the visual effects not done it's a
metal arm it's not like we're trying to
remove a mustache
oh [ __ ] it I'll do it myself I'm cable
and I'm from the future and I like
blowing [ __ ] up
oh no sheriff Deadpool you know you're a
lot taller in the shut up you little
[ __ ] take this regeneration powers
activate that's not something simple I
got the stuns to help you Oh buddy
they're done already oh wow that was
unrealistic we fast okay it
your time's up you dumb [ __ ] well that's
just lazy writing
[Music]
[Music]
everyone's got their thing
[Music]
maybe it's a breakup a death
[Music]
accident
whatever it is you used to be one thing
now you're something else
we all have our own problems
our own issues
demons
[Music]